stormed you can see him there much  national broadcaster nos in the last  couple of hours before being arrested he  was demanding airtime you see there him  dropping age Gumba he was armed and  several officers we've seen being  involved in that operation a little bit  of information reaching us from The  Associated Press news service that the  gunmen who stormed the studio as you can  see they're being taken into custody  claimed whilst he was standing there to  be from hackers collected from a group  known as hackers collective we know that  security was very tight to understand  from the director of the national  broadcaster but a man managed to  overcome that enter the building right  into this year those pictures you're  looking at as she came from nos bring  you more on that story as we get it